you see we are all connected through the
holy body
when you need only accept the sacred
gift
Christ like
she did
Temperance child
I've taken delivery of preparing some
entertainment for you ah the
entertainment without further Ado Big
Island night protects the princess fan
yeah
I'll make a cheat for you move
she's always like this with you how
about you open fire instead of your
mouth
long time no see Richard krauser why
you can't save her
you can't save anyone
what's gonna happen with me
you gotta keep moving forward we will
beat this together
[Music]
thanks
let us rescue the princess you gotta
hurt yourself
[Music]
this is kind of fun
ahead you're kidding
ah yes the time has come
like I told you
I'm gonna get you home safe
ready to die again exalt all Leon and
Let It Be song
this time
it has to be different
[Music]
well now time to call some Mayhem
PlayStation